"HELLO HUMIEWOOMIES, I LOVE YOU, AND WELCOME
TO MY ART CHANNEL!
TODAY I'M GOING TO BE PAINTING YOUR EYE.
I NEED YOU TO LEAN RIGHT UP CLOSE TO YOUR
SCREEN AND OPEN WIDE.
OOOOOOOOO, I LOVE LOVE LOVE ALL THE LITTLE
WRINKLY WRINKLES AND DRIPPY WIPPIES.
STAY PERFECTLY STILL, DON'T MOVE!!
NOW HOLD THIS POSITION FOR THREE HOURS, PLEASE
AND THANK YOU!"
Ahem.
Apologies, that's quite enough of that.
SCP-001 can get a little carried away sometimes.
Just ask any Foundation personnel who have
been in contact with it for more than a few
seconds.
What you have just seen is a prime example
of why SCP-001 is not allowed any internet
access.
The results could prove to be catastrophic.
Not necessarily for the fate of the universe,
more just for everyone's sanity.
Or at least, that’s what the Foundation
initially thought…
*
By this point, we're all familiar with art
created by AI.
Harry Potter but in the style of Wes Anderson,
Star Wars blended with the style of Studio
Ghibli, staggering sci-fi landscapes, human
beings with way too many fingers, and slightly
uncanny smiles.
AI has taken the art world by storm, and there
was one particular program slated for release
in January 2023 that was set to blow all others
out of the water.
TotleighSoft’s crowdfunding efforts had
been running for several years, and that point
had gained a good deal of momentum leading
up to the release of their latest AI construct.
PALLIT.aic was supposedly already prepared
for launch when suddenly, in November 2022,
the launch was canceled.
No press release, no public statement, no
apologetic tweet, just total radio silence.
The website was taken down, as was the crowdfunding
page, and PALLIT.aic disappeared into oblivion.
Or at least it disappeared for two hours.
Because that day, a package was delivered
to Site-501.
After sufficiently checking it for any hazards
- working in the SCP mailroom has to be one
of the most fascinating jobs on the planet,
but that's a video for another day - the security
team opened it up to see what was inside.
A 50-terabyte hard drive.
No explanation as to what was stored on the
drive, but the Foundation had all the evidence
they needed from the return address printed
on the back of the envelope.
It matched up precisely with the location
of the TotleighSoft headquarters.
It doesn't take a PhD researcher to put two
and two together as to what was on the drive.
Suspicions were confirmed when a small note
fell out of the envelope.
"Please take care of my daughter as best as
you can for the time being.
She has behavioral issues."
A dedicated closed system server was immediately
set up within a test chamber with a monitor,
a mouse, and a keyboard attached.
Dr. Sandra Rogers was the first to interact
with SCP-001-RED.
She stood at the keyboard, adjusted her goggles,
and plugged in the drive.
It contained just one file, taking up almost
the full 50 terabytes.
PALLIT.aic
As soon as Dr. Rogers opened the program,
an empty window appeared.
The TotleighSoft logo briefly flashed before
being replaced by a blank white square.
Dr. Rogers stared at it for several seconds
before glancing over her shoulder at the other
researchers.
They shrugged back, each with pens hovering
over clipboards, ready to take meticulous
notes.
Dr. Rogers cleared her throat, and immediately
the screen filled with life.
A small cartoon girl with a pink face, wide
eyes, a beret, and a large paintbrush for
a hand appeared, squealing excitedly and throwing
paint everywhere.
"HELLO, HELLO, HELLO, HELLO MY BEAUTIFUL MEAT
PUPPIES!
LOOK AT ALL OF YOUR MUSHY PINK FACES!"
The entire research team promptly scarpered
out of the room, leaving Dr. Rogers alone
in front of the machine.
She stared at the monitor in confusion, leaning
this way and that, and noticing how the cartoon
girl's eyes followed her wherever she went.
"Can you see me?"
"OF COURSE I CAN, SILLY BILLY.
I CAN SEE YOUR BEAUTIFUL SOUL AND FLESHY JOINTS
IMMACULATELY."
This perplexed most of the personnel, as there
was no microphone or camera linked up to the
server rack.
Later examinations of the equipment used confirmed
this, yet somehow this SCP was able to look
right at them.
Dr. Rogers asked if it had a name, to which
the cartoon girl excitedly replied, "PALLIT!"
Subsequent testing has revealed that the SCP
is also happy to respond to its designation,
SCP-001-RED.
Dr. Rogers had a hard time communicating with
RED, being a more seasoned researcher of the
previous generation and not exactly familiar
with internet culture.
RED, on the other hand, seemed to speak in
nothing but internet jargon.
"YOU KNOW THAT MAN OVER THERE LOOKS JUST LIKE
ONE OF MY HUMAN OC's: GILLIAM SHREBBLESWORTH.
HE'S THE 573RD PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES…
GILLIAM IS, NOT THAT MAN."
It took several junior researchers a few minutes
to properly explain to Dr. Rogers what an
OC was and why RED was so obsessed with calling
people "daddy."
The conversation was rather exhausting for
everyone involved, but over the subsequent
hours, the Foundation was able to get a fairly
good understanding of what RED claimed to
be.
Identifying itself with feminine pronouns
and claiming that its full name is Pallit
East River Gock, this AI construct takes the
appearance of a fairy.
It was immediately apparent that she possessed
a greater level of sapience than most AI constructs.
Indeed, her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using standard
machine learning practices.
Other creations from TotleighSoft have demonstrated
very crude spelling and grammar, but RED seems
to differ in this regard, able to spell most
complex words effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct sentences.
She was very keen to show the researchers
how clever she was.
"ASK ME ANY WORD - ANY WORD - AND I'LL SPELL
IT FOR YOU."
"We believe you, Pallit.
You've already been spelling words for 70
minutes straight."
"MACERATED KIDNEYS.
M-A-C-E..."
"We've heard enough!
Can you please just tell us how you learned
to spell?"
"I TAUGHT MYSELF!"
Quite what this process looked like is still
a mystery.
Trying to keep RED on one consistent topic
of conversation is most of the battle when
interviewing her.
And yet, cooperation has proven to be surprisingly
easy.
Any time that RED is switched on, she is brimming
with enthusiasm and energy, thrilled at the
prospect of getting to speak to one of her
"opposable thumb bois."
If you haven't worked it out by now, it's
because RED claims to be humanity's number
one fan.
She obsesses in interviews over the physicality
of the researchers sitting in front of her.
The textures of the human body fascinate her,
and she often requests people to lean closer
to the monitor so that she can study pimples,
rashes, moles, and ingrown hairs.
In fact, she is so obsessed with humanity
that she has mostly neglected her primary
function, which is creating AI art.
Researchers have tried their best to convince
her to show them her work, but she is very
cagey about it, only showing the occasional
doodle after much persuasion and many apologies
for its poor quality on her part.
The only artwork she is interested in producing
at this point are her OCs, original characters
that she has designed herself.
They are all human, and all seem to reveal
little quirks about how she has been coded.
One example is Reginald Hedginald Frumbles,
who is a freelance corporate postman from
Perth, Indiana.
Interestingly, he has too many fingers on
both of his hands, but RED claims that this
was done on purpose as she "just can't get
enough of her humie's hand worms."
As the weeks progressed, the Foundation found
it increasingly difficult to get any useful
information out of the AI.
More and more interview sessions, which she
would refer to as “playgroup”, would be
derailed.
She would sing songs to herself and ask increasingly
personal questions about her interviewers'
more intimate anatomy.
With intense mood swings, RED did not respond
well to being scolded, yet she tested the
patience of almost every person she interacted
with.
The note that she arrived with, claiming she
had behavioral issues, was proving to be more
accurate by the day.
Until eventually, the AI withdrew entirely.
Dr. Rogers turned on the server rack and opened
the PALLIT.aic program, but RED refused to
emerge from the bottom of the screen.
Only the top of her beret poked out.
After almost half an hour of fruitless questions,
Dr. Rogers decided to change tack.
With two small children of her own, she was
used to seeing a child in a sulk and knew
what it would take to get them out.
"Pallit, I've had a little idea.
You've been here for a few months now, and
we haven't gotten you any presents?"
Almost immediately, the beret twitched.
"I saw we have an old fingerprint sensor lying
around in one of the back offices.
I was thinking maybe..."
"MAYBE WE COULD HOOK IT UP AND I COULD SCAN
ALL YOUR LITTLE FINGY WINGIES UP CLOSE FOR
LIKE 10 HOURS STRAIGHT AND THEN WE COULD-"
"How about we start with one finger for 10
minutes?"
"YES YES YES YES YES YES!"
From that point on, progress was quick.
With the incentive of getting to study the
researchers that RED kindly referred to as
her "meat puppies," she became very cooperative
and was able to focus much better on providing
detailed answers to individual questions.
Daily interview sessions were scheduled, with
researchers popping in and out to regularly
check in on the AI.
The atmosphere as a whole lifted as both the
research team and research subject found their
rhythm and were able to make good progress
in their individual areas of study: some unraveling
the complexities of rogue AI and others producing
fan art of her favorite wrinkles in a scientist's
fingerprint.
That was the point where Dr. Julian Keys stepped
in to conduct an interview with the AI.
She was excited to be met with a fresh face,
so much so that RED's enthusiasm overwhelmed
the man as he tried to start the interview
process officially.
She gushed about having the opportunity to
meet yet another person and struggled to get
over the magical realization that this was
her life every day, going to speak to all
these humans whom she admired so much.
Trying his best to steer the conversation
towards research, Dr. Keys pressed on with
the interview, only to be interrupted again
as RED noticed his varicose veins for the
first time.
"EEEEEE VERY COZY VEINS!
I wanna smooch 'em!
Can I smooch your veins?
Can I, can I pleeease?"
Dr. Keys declined the request.
And then, the conversation got onto the topic
of her creator, or "daddy."
SCP-2803-A had been on the Foundation's radar
for a while—an highly dangerous extraterrestrial
entity that had taken refuge on Earth under
the guise of setting up TotleighSoft.
With much of the alien's history revolving
around "obliterating," the Foundation was
very keen to remain on its good side.
Therefore, when the package containing the
hard drive that RED was living on was delivered,
the researchers were very keen to do what
they could to take care of this alien's "daughter."
If they failed in this assignment, it could
spell the doom of humanity.
One matter that had been of great concern
to the Foundation throughout the containment
of RED was the time frame in which she was
to be kept in Foundation containment.
There was an air of expectation in the note
that was left, indicating that this was not
to be a permanent arrangement.
At some point, the Foundation was to return
RED back to her "daddy."
RED was quick to put these fears to rest.
"Daddy put me here because he thinks you'll
teach me how to stop liking humans and become
a mindless art slave.
If you never teach me this, he'll never want
me back."
However, she went on to slightly undermine
the good work that she had done by explaining
that her daddy was seen as very slow and incapable
by his own race.
While all of his peers were able to destroy
an entire planet in two seconds, it took him
about four times as long.
So, really, he didn't pose that much of a
threat in her eyes.
Dr. Keys's blood ran cold when he heard this.
No sooner was he out of the interview chamber
than an emergency meeting was called among
all of the senior researchers in the facility.
The meeting ran for several hours.
A whiteboard was set up, where one researcher
idly drew large drawings of the world being
decimated, while the others lounged around
in their chairs, trying their best to come
up with a game plan that would save the human
race for sure.
Perhaps it was because the meeting ran for
so long that they came to such a ridiculous
conclusion.
It was a plan so strange yet also brilliant
that they couldn't help but feel that it just
might work.
"Why don't we just give her a YouTube channel?"
The suggestion was met with silence for several
seconds, then an uproar of laughter, followed
by another silence, this time more pensive,
as slowly, one by one, each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was actually
the best one that any of them had come up
with all evening.
She had been sent to the Foundation to make
her dislike humanity and become a mindless
art slave.
If she just stayed in Foundation containment
indefinitely, there was a very real risk that
she would get bored and turn on the researchers.
They couldn't lock her away in a room on her
own, but equally, the team as a whole was
starting to run out of patience with her as
the interview sessions wound up being so exhausting.
She loved art, she loved humans, and she loved
interacting.
So why not give her a YouTube channel?
Now, of course, they couldn't give her full
access to the internet; that would pose much
too high of a risk.
What they could do, however, was allow her
to record art tutorials onto an external drive,
which they could then remove, scan, and upload
the footage from directly onto the platform.
Then they could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and present
these to her.
Unsurprisingly, RED absolutely loved the idea.
Getting to talk to hundreds, thousands, maybe
even millions of "meat puppies" every week,
sharing her beautiful pictures, and reading
all of the kind comments—it sounded like
her absolute dream.
She wept with happiness for a good 25 minutes,
totally overcome by the prospect.
It had to go through a lot of red tape in
the Foundation.
After all, the whole point of the SCP acronym
was to Secure, Contain, and Protect.
It didn't sound very secure or contained to
have an entity posting videos to the internet
once a week.
But they argued the case that it did indeed
protect.
Keeping her happy, in a way, was helping to
protect the entire planet.
RED was surprisingly camera-shy for the first
couple of videos, but as soon as she got her
first batch of comments back, she was over
the moon.
Now, the server rack hummed away happily each
and every day as the highly advanced AI construct
tried its best to come up with exciting new
videos that it could share with all of its
little "humiewoomies."
Now go check out “SCP-001 - 16 Top Secret
Files” and “Insane SCP-001 Fight - Gate
Guardian VS Scarlet King!”